brian i see that you're trying to go to
another place you don't want to be here
right now am i right i told me yeah
anywhere else that could happen but with
a virtual private network i thought you
got me like a ticket that barbados no
that that would be too expensive
although the money that we make from
this barbados yeah but i've not paid for
it yet i need to wait for the
surf shop money to come through these
guys can take you anywhere in the world
virtually so say you want to go to
america and watch netflix over in
america because the americans are always
going oh i've got amazing netflix like
the netflix here is incredible babe
they've got the good stuff that they
really do they get like all the good
raunchy anyway the whole point is that i
can take myself anywhere in the world to
watch tv from anywhere else and if i go
somewhere else in the world and i want
to watch say
match of the day you can't do that
outside oh yes have you got barbados
exactly still got it i can still get it
that's me badass and not only that but
it also keeps you safe when you're in
public so if you're on say open public
wi-fi you just put your vpn on it
protects you a little bit more but not
only that it doesn't only do it on your
laptop it does it on your phone your
tablet your pc in the corner it does it
on any object that you have that is
digital that you need to have a vpn on
and are capable of having said all on
one account as well you don't have to
have a separate account do you know the
discount
yeah 83
83 off not only that three months for
free but also they've got a 30-day
money-back guarantee so if you don't
like it in the first 30 days boom money
back don't worry about it see you later
the first three months of free extra
yeah wow
so convinced you're going to love this
genuinely i like the confidence i love
the confidence i love surfing i love
sharks i love
sexy people that's my cue anyway all you
got to do is use code jordy and check
out 83 off three months for free 30-day
money-back guarantee and so many more
benefits from being on surfshark go and
take a look right now helps us out it
helps you out and it's a great product
but for now
enjoy the podcast
three dogs on the t-shirt three dogs on
the chest
anywhere else you're gonna
experiment with this uh
no i just like
animals my uh my tattoo is a little bit
going for the word like jungle themed
dogs in the jungle
i don't know urban jungle sort of thing
they do have dogs in the jungle the
mighty jungle
where the lion sleeps tonight yeah but
you know they'll have chihuahuas wild
dogs right wild dogs yeah like wolves
sort of thing i actually read an article
about um
a woman who was savaged by pitbulls
recently
wow and she woke up
i think it was on tmz there's a lot of
stuff on she woke up on tmz uh no the
odds are
on tmz basically um
she woke up with her without any arms
sorry she was asleep for the whole
experience or they said she was saying
she just passed out and then she when
she woke up in the hospital she had no
arms and no and also they ate into her
colon
and she had to be uh resedated what was
in when she woke up they they had to
resedate her yeah so it said she had to
be resedated after waking up from a coma
to learn she no longer had arms or call
on and perhaps something else dot dot
link in bio sorry what's the something
else so we talk did the dogs basically
eat her vagina do you think [__] me what
a way to start a podcaster pretty
horrific really i mean most dog owners
are irresponsible enough to let their
dog off a lead anyway but then other
people like london nobody cleans up the
dog [__] really that really annoys me
there's been just piles sitting around
near my flat recently that sort of stuff
i genuinely think if you're responsible
enough and you think you're responsible
enough to get a dog be responsible
enough to pick up after the meeting
there's a lesson
kids i'm just looking at some of the
other things on tmz why do you read you
read a lot of trash you know yeah but
it's it's more just i sort of glance
over it it's not like i'm taking it it's
not like that i don't look at the daily
mail or the
economy yeah i don't i ignore them it's
tmz just for like it's like [__]
news it never really bothers me yeah
yeah you know what i mean it's like
british trans transgender cyclist emily
bridges says she's had to deactivate her
social media to stop the targeted abuse
there has been a lot of abuse of
transgender athletes recently because is
that abuse though is it is no way some
people will be giving them abuse and
that is that's that's probably what i
mean that's just the internet isn't it
like we're all getting abuse on the
internet that doesn't make you special
no i don't
i just mean like the one thing that the
internet doesn't discriminate on is it
will just ruin everyone anyone anyone
and anyone who for any reason it doesn't
matter how many years you've been
winning the minute you take an l
you're getting hammered for it i just
got a message yesterday off some kid who
said um yeah you look you actually
laughed i remember i was sitting at the
computer getting getting the show ready
and i just heard brian go
he he messaged me saying something like
um
i i will be there for your downfall yeah
um some middle eastern looking fella and
uh oh yeah i'm just gonna call it i'll
see you i mean no to be fair he did look
like he's from the middle yeah i was
laughing and he was like uh
something like i'm glad you're not as
successful as you used to be i thought
you haven't seen my balance part love
you yeah all my new cars yeah
but that's the thing is once you
once you develop that level of thick
skin it's just definitely it just
bounces off me like well yeah you say
that but i mean like a pool toy are you
sure it bounces off you are you sure
there's not like some sort of something
in there that is impacted every time
that someone says something nasty i
fully admit like a few years ago that
definitely had you know at your low low
point yeah but i think because i was law
mentally anywhere leaves you open to
yeah a bit like illness
yeah it's like yeah you're more likely
to catch something else when you're
already immune systems down right i mean
so yeah whereas now i'm as strong as a
[__] bull mentally like i feel i feel
pretty you feel that way don't get me
wrong i have my low days but that's
that's don't know what's going on with
me the internet doesn't impact me at all
anymore apart from tmz well i mean
should we
[Laughter]
i heard what you said the other day
about you hating them having penises and
that yeah yeah well i hate i hate anyone
who's got a penis obviously uh cis white
male um
i think that there should be a
discussion around it because i don't
think we quite understand
what we're doing here and i get the
positive affirmation of anyone's
identity but i believe that in sport
there are we need to look at how we do
these rules well
it's very clear about it it's very clear
about it i've figured it out right sorry
i've already thought of it yeah okay
what have you thought
in your life
no but i think
we currently have the olympics yeah we
also have um the olympics for people who
have uh different uh abilities abilities
different levels of abilities different
kinds of abilities i think we need
something transgender category where
people can compete whether they've
transitioned from female to male or male
to female whatever they want yeah right
because because the difference in
like natural athleticism is so
clear from someone who used to be a man
and is now a woman versus someone who's
been a woman their whole life it doesn't
make it fair much like if i just said to
one of the greatest swimmers of all time
uh pop them in the disabled swimming
category and when go on then yeah you
know it doesn't make sense to do that
there's a reason that you physically
there's a reason that sport physically
discriminates well it it
deliberately matches you up with people
who are similar inability to use to make
it interesting exactly so take boxing
for example there's a reason we have
weight classes okay because we don't
want an unfair match up yeah i don't
think it makes me discriminate directly
ksi doesn't want weight classes yes i
would definitely go against your views i
think he's recently rescinded some of
the things you said about thor
i loved his confidence though i'll put
it back
i rated the comments
i've never i've never seen someone more
just blindly convinced i love that they
could beat the hell out of the strongest
man in the world yeah
this is the thing right
confidence takes you all over the world
bro absolutely and that [__] has
got the most confidence ever and that's
what i love about him and you know what
i literally thought i thought when he
said that i thought i've got a ring for
doll and tell him to talk him up with
this this is not a good idea the funny
thing is the sidemen podcast is sneaky
good yeah it's yeah it's quite oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah we're the best
podcaster
i'll pick them all up
oh it's actually a really good job
oh
sorry we've interviewed him enough times
to have a little bit of an impression
no this is
he is
my favorite bit of that whole clip was
harry like you look on his face
he's gone yeah he's [__] he's gone
because harry's an old school fight fan
and he has god moments though doesn't he
where jj sort of has the ultimate
confidence and i think that's probably
gotten him in the ring with people like
that and paul brought him to how else do
you achieve that in life without
thinking you can do anything yeah i rate
it but
i think i was onto something there i
think you were sorry i didn't mean to
boxing away
youtuber prove
you
rightfully group people in with a people
of their own size strength ability and
it's only fair and that's man versus man
you don't put um a light weight in there
with the heavy weight you just don't do
it because it's also not entertaining
well yeah in the same way and
also you need a way for everyone to have
their golden opportunity to compete and
that's what we're doing right now is
we're removing competition
and what we're
like for example if it was just any if
we had one world title and everyone had
to fight for it you know if you're five
foot seven you ain't ever winning the
world title right there's nothing for
you you're getting [__] beat up do
you know what i mean by big big guys and
in many ways like sport is
agnostic to your
personal lifestyle change like it
doesn't need to it's not relevant your
personal lifestyle change whether you
choose to be a man or a woman it's not
about that category no it's about the
competition between all these people and
it being a fair couple right and that's
where i feel sorry for example for some
of these uh these ladies out here who've
obviously been lifelong women dedicated
their whole life to be people by the way
might feel like they've been a woman
their whole life in a man's body but i
get your point no i i just mean
genetically speaking they have not had
the advantages of having testosterone
they were born that way yeah right so
their bodies did not develop in the same
physical way
as as the people who were men
transitioned into women uh physically
speaking yeah and and
so they're like well much like a
lightweight in a heavyweight boxing
tournament it will feel unfair they're
like i'm [__] yeah right you know what
i mean i've got all the skills i've done
everything i was supposed to do i just
want a fair playground well they have
there have been some instances where
people have transitioned
over from one uh
gender or sex to another right and
they've gone from being
very much not average but middle of
their class in say a men's sport to top
of their club well let's let's
there's no women going from women to men
and all of a sudden go on i think i'm
going to take on eddie hall in the
weightlifting it's not happening there's
some impressive female weight lifters
out there amazing but amazing
physiologically people who were born a
man regard are at an advantage in every
single physical competition against a
woman especially we're just bigger
stronger faster you you ever seen the
realis you ever seen the relays where
they do mixed mixed gender relays
[__] hell right you could have a man
pick up the baton from a woman and the
other woman could be right the way
around the track and he'll
catch her up overtake her and make them
look slow as [__] and these are amazing
female runners the the difference
between an elite level male and elite
level woman as serena williams has
commented on she's like if you put me in
with the men i would get i'd be last
i'd be beaten
six love six love i'll be out against
like bottom of the run male tennis
players because i don't have a physical
strength to compete with these guys
but she is she's also talking in the
sense of
the best woman against the best men no
no she would very much beat the average
man yeah if you turned under the court
you're getting smoked well actually i'm
talking yeah i'm talking about any pro
tennis player what she said is i could
have made it the top 500 men are all
beating her that's not that that she
she's aware of that and this is
not a slant on her no she is the
greatest one of the greatest tennis
players
and i don't i but i don't compare her to
men because i've i've got the
sort of sensibility to look and go she
is a great female tennis player and i
can still compare i can still look at
that as a great achievement i don't need
to put her in there with a men to prove
how good she is yeah and also she's also
made her body so that she would compete
in a female tournament because she was
given those set of rules before in her
life so then she went i'll make my body
so it suits these rules so three so
beautiful and powerful it is a beautiful
powerful have you seen king richard the
film uh i haven't no um he wanted to i i
deliberately uh avoided it knowing he's
an abuser of uh comedians um yeah i'm
sort of big on comedians um right i've
always had i've always fancied a
serenade but i get your point about
having your own category of transgender
athletes i think that what's the harm it
just removes the argument immediately
and goes if this is the way the world's
going and we have to adapt things and
change things which is a good thing
sometimes then then do it you know what
i mean but but right now you've got
women who are like lifelong athletes
going like [__] hell physiologically
someone with male characteristics can
now compete against me but this is part
of this is part of what i feel we're not
offending anyone out there
it's not it's not so much saying that
you don't have a say or you don't have
you don't have equity in sport or you're
not welcome in sport or that if i turned
up at a tennis court and the transgender
woman said to me hey you wanna play some
tennis i go sorry i'm not the same
gender as you i don't play tennis with
this lot like i'd go yeah of course
let's pick up some recordings who's
better
would it have been they would have
transitioned from male to female and
right so technically it would be into
it'll be fair sort of see i'm doing
ramadan again good old ramadan the
family
good old ramadan as they say yeah
fasting for 30 days
could you
do that so so let me just remind myself
just yeah because obviously you're up on
the
rules yeah which is fine because you're
not one of them definitely not it's like
it's like you saying to them hey you're
up on the old atheist rules not sure
they're not in the atheist really no but
the old diagnostic rules or whatever
spiritual why are you just on some
obscure [__] you know what i mean i'm
i'm on some
you've not really worked it out that's
fair for the votes so
but tell me tell me what time you can
start eating and what time you have to
finish eating by so the way it works is
you can you're not allowed to eat from
sunrise to sunset so what time is that
roughly uh roughly so about 5 a.m until
8 p.m
you can't eat you can't eat or drink
so i can't do that right now thanks for
that
i can't do that that's mad that though i
think
no offense you know no offense to anyone
it's mad to a lot of people who i don't
think i've heard of the concept no i i i
just think some people are cheating i
bet you they are
well some people take days off like if
you i mean what's the point then you're
either going to do that or you're not
going to do it but that's how i live
like 30 days yeah right you're either
all in or all out well yeah just you
make a great muslim no but don't come on
bro convert what's your problem don't
bang on you're not even one of them
either you're just i'm not one of them
either you're right but i'm just doing
it for the brony points or whatever
do you think that i don't know why when
i first started doing it did you go
you're just doing it because you want to
you know you want to impress your woman
there's no doubt in my mind that they're
a percentage of your decision when i
first started doing it of course sure
you're only a bloke i'm open-minded well
you're an atheist for a start so
agnostic atheist but yeah sure i'm in
some
funky [__] so no you've you've you've
always been a storage atheist as long as
but the point i'm making more so is
there was a few things that went through
my head
so what did you think when i first
because so so it's like because you
haven't raised
muslims at that time she must be [__]
amazing in bed for this [__] i'll tell
you sure but then it's like
no no offense you know flu yeah
we love you and all of that but you're
gorgeous i just thought it must have
something to do with that sure but also
i just thought you were wrong it was
love
i just thought he will do [__]
anything more [__] love right for
love
yeah um use that word and then um i
remember seeing you coming in to work
looking noticeably
disheveled
like
because you're not at the time actually
i think when you first did it you were
you felt out of shape yeah right and i
remember there was an inkling in your
head of like this is a good way to give
myself some discipline and you but this
is the thing you went a bit mental i
think you your mental health wasn't
great at the time right and you started
running during the day as well almost
to compile the misery it yeah yeah and
there was a bit of me that was like what
does he do he's [__] lost
like he not anorexia but like i just
thought this guy's just like
i just need to let him work this out i
really don't know what yeah there's
points where you go
should i ask him if he's all right yeah
probably all right yeah all right
because yeah he looks all right no but
you didn't though that was that was i
think like
like i just remember thinking like i
think he's pushing this a bit hard i was
definitely pushing it harder yeah and
i enjoyed that yeah i i could tell that
you
you like a challenge and and um
yeah there was a bit of there was a lot
going on for you and i didn't really
understand it in my head i'm like at
that time i was probably eating more
than i'd eaten as well so we were
optimistic yeah i was really getting fat
at that point so
there's there was a lot going through my
head honor honor
the fact that there's this is a part of
a religion like i understand
that religions all of them do strange
things to people who aren't in that
religion yeah everyone else's religion
is funky and weird to people so yeah
it's just you can't see that your
religion is thank you exactly exactly so
like you know there's all sorts of weird
traditions that people have so this
isn't me
singling out one i just think they're
all a bit odd obviously everything looks
funky to other humans like everyone in
the world thinks that other cultures
yeah culture is weird so in any place
yeah so but in my head i was like i just
don't think to quote chris rock yeah
that on judgment day my diet's gonna
come into question like i i i think the
way i treat people
and and the purity of my heart if said
heaven did exist is what it would be
judged on not
did you do your fasting did you do your
ramadans oh you had a ham sandwich there
so we're gonna have to but you shouldn't
have had the ham sandwich
so yeah that's almost like double rule
yeah but exactly that's what i'm saying
so that it does seem silly but
um that's not me trying to offend anyone
because i know it's something people are
passionate about we really i'm really
chanting on this one no
good luck with your lifestyle because
i'm pretty sure there's some people out
there within your own religion who ain't
feeling good about you yeah but um but
others who feel great so you know but i
just mean like you know i know that this
is a
semi
sensitive but i do hope that people who
are watching this who are practicing
ramadan
don't take this as an insult it's just
like we've said it's it's to me as
someone who's never fasted a day in his
life clearly uh it's a bit weird however
i am getting frustrated with my diet and
i am i was asking you about the other
day not not uh to go and convert to
islam but to look at fasting although
you've got the bed
yeah what not yeah they're not theirs
are different though they shape them
completely differently right they seem
to cut all of this off and leave it like
a lot of air although there's a few
people why are you going
i don't know i'm just doing the ramadan
thing well can you not any further come
on
in for a party i'll get the rule book
and i'll let you know
yeah well no uh infrared
yeah what are you in for a shackle out
for a pound yeah um i
i do it for uh health reasons first of
all like i genuinely started to feel the
health benefits of fasting health
benefits of fasting yeah so so you're
depriving yourself of stuff but it's
benefiting you well i'm interested well
obviously
this is an alien
um
when you fast your body does begin to
uh
naturally go through certain cycles of
things and but you have to fast for a
certain amount of time depression
anxiety
yeah i'm going through all that [__]
right now um you tweeted about something
like uh mental clarity on day three yeah
every time i've done it um
by day three you begin to feel a form of
mental clarity that is not
what is can you explain what you're
experiencing there so it's yeah so it's
not about and at what point in the day
and when when you see mental clarity
what what does that mean right because i
think a lot of people a few people went
oh you're so pretentious what you're
tweeting and i did read it back and
think i agree
but it did
i oh god i'm glad you're being honest
today aren't you i've read it i thought
you went [__] this is just such a
like
by the way everyone i'm doing i'm doing
ramadan
i did i said that to flu i went i
tweeted it and she went first of all
you've broken the rule and i was like
what she went you're not meant to
advertise it that you're doing any of
this
hashtag so yeah i think the scc are
gonna look after me for this this is
[__]
no no [__] advertising i've done
enough of that over the years yeah
genuinely
but i did um
so day one and two you're a little bit
not foggy but like sometimes you get
very hungry sometimes you get very
thirsty sometimes you get very tired and
by day three it seems that your body is
like processed a lot of that so it's
almost like a not a hangover feeling but
like um
there's this always this weird feeling
and it comes in waves around your body
about you get hungry here or you get
hungry in your head or you're hungry in
weird ways
and then by day three there's a weird
sort of i can only describe it as like
mental clarity which is not about words
it's not about you can't get more words
out you can't think in a clearer way to
get your work done but you feel
different well you feel like you can
concentrate easier there are parts of
concentration you can and also i only
have one
reference for this and it's when i tried
keto right and did that work for you so
i remember feeling early on
like hell
and then once the hell subsided i did
kind of feel like oh i'm getting used to
this and i'm coming into some sort of
zone right now
i thought and this may be right or wrong
that it was because i felt so [__]
initially right that when i finally came
back to feeling okay
my brain was going wow this is amazing
but it was just amazing in comparison to
the hell i'd been feeling because i was
starting is that true no i think you
actually had some real clarity i know
honestly i've got no idea but in my head
i was like is this just an elastic bond
effect on my brain where my brain's
going wow we feel great now but we
maybe we didn't maybe you tricked
yourself i'm saying we yeah me and my
mind having a conversation we're a team
up here aren't we guys go team how many
of us have that oh hey [__] that right
up what you should have done that why
are you fasting because obviously you're
not
um listening but you know your missus is
and all of that but you don't have to do
it so why bother no i get it but you
know when we have russell brand on the
podcast not long ago and he was talking
about how different religions all have
very similar ideas in them so you know
christianity has lent where you give
something up i think this ramadan is
similar to lent in a sense where they
sort of and i'm not saying they are the
same thing they're not why do they
celebrate it so much because that's
all over
yeah at the end yeah and it uh obviously
in this time you're meant to pray five
times a day
so so what do you do
sometimes i meditate at the same time
that uh flu says they're meant to pray
so i won't pray but i'll just take she
clocks on and you go in the other room
and clock on in your own way exactly
yeah but you said russell brown says
that so i was talking about so that was
more like i don't believe in i don't
believe in the god that christianity
lays out or the god that islam lays out
right now i don't believe that way i
don't feel that you know but what i do
feel is there are common human
experiences that people have experienced
in their life that you can give some
credence to and people throughout by
credence it gives some weight to it so
throughout the age people have said like
this civilization these people fasted or
these people would fast for this amount
of time or fasting in this way is good
for you so i believe that in some sense
there is an element of truth or like a
kernel of truth in the fasting and there
is an importance in it and if you do it
for 30 days and so when i first thought
this if i do it for 30 days i'll see
what the impact is so after 30 days i
kind of felt like a reset in my body i
felt that you know all the bad habits
that i've worked up of like but you know
getting pizza or getting burgers every
day or and you and i like we want
convenience you know what i mean you and
i and often go should we just get burger
king or whatever it is
and i found after the 30 days
i felt calmer in a sense probably
because i've been meditating but also
i'd
dropped a lot of the bad habits because
i couldn't do them during the day i
couldn't go and get coffee whenever i
felt like it i couldn't go and get a
burger or a bad piece of food whenever i
wanted it
it stops those habits what else is there
though so
there is something else and i can't
remember what it's called but there is
another article let me find it on
twitter
the reason i bring that up is because
from memory yeah you did pick a lot of
those bad habits back up immediately
like what
well coffee and pizza isn't that no no
but what i mean is so i don't drink
nearly as much coffee as i do in um as i
did before oh really not nearly as much
like i would i would be on like three or
four coffees a day
that's a lot of coffee fasting for
health longevity no nobel prize winning
research on cell aging japanese cell
biologists i'm not even going to attempt
this name won the nobel peace prize for
medicine in 2016 for his research on how
cells recycle and renew their content a
process called auto f i want to say
feiji autophagy autofacie
um
fasting activates autophagy
maybe it's out auto
or tougher i don't know how to say
anyway which helps slow down the aging
process and has positive impact on cell
renewal his work was studied uh in yeast
so not in the human body but in yeast so
it worked on yeast yeah it works on me
all i'm saying is it might be a [__]
it also i had a bit of a problem with my
stomach where for a little while i i was
like i feel like i had like
not ibs but like if i ate anything bad
i'd just be like oh this doesn't make me
feel good
i fasted it's indian food
no it was more like i had a lot of like
just meets
for that time right
and it made me feel better now that
you're
doing this
and you know it's for allah and all of
that but it isn't on my behalf but it is
for her i'm trying to understand what
she's thinking and what her and what our
family think do you know what i mean
like you know we're raising my son
muslim like obviously he'll have
critical thinking skills that i believe
some religious people skip over but um
with you pointing them out every step of
the way yeah with that in there but he
will it's not going to come as a bit of
a conflict within the family though
because obviously
um
your
your your missus family
full full belief
no so
so
naturally
in any religion and i'll just keep it as
vague as possible because i think this
stands for all of them the idea is that
you're right you you believe it word for
word it is what it is absolutely you
know and i know a lot of people try to
go oh there's metaphors in there but
that that to me is when people are
trying to sort of pick and choose what
they
really
yeah like you're don't get me wrong
i think it makes sense that some of the
texts and the scriptures will be
metaphorically saying the world didn't
flood well i believe that's actually one
of the things that they got right it did
happen but it's not in the way like he
didn't build the boat and keep all the
people no but there there were people
who survived the flood due to a big boat
or you know but there's actually
physical evidence i think jack could
have got on the door though there's
there's physical evidence out there
where people have done their research
and actually i'd love to get someone on
the podcast about this where uh like the
great cataclysms that the earth went
through yeah and how civilizations were
basically lost and now
you know things like the pyramids
allegedly uh were there long before the
egyptians were even but you know how
true that is i don't know but anyway
going back to it like
to me if you are going to be again in
for a penny and for a pound right if
you're religious
to me
like if you want to say yeah i believe
in a god like don't get me wrong anyone
can do whatever they want but i don't
understand it as much when people sort
of
um look at religion like a buffet like
they go well i'll have some of that
here yeah i'll still have the pork like
but like to me it's like i sleep with a
thousand people but as long as i don't
eat pork i'm definitely adhering to the
religion whereas me
i'll eat a pig's ass if they cook her
right right yeah um and that's part of
sleeping with them
so yeah to me
it's going to be tricky because you've
obviously got people around your little
one who want to
uh want to teach them the the ways yeah
of the force and uh you are on the dark
side essentially you are atheist in some
senses oh you're atheist which is
completely
opposition with that and that
it's quite interesting how you approach
her because i don't know i'm sure
there's other people going through a
similar situation
you always need to discuss that so you
know you being you
in your head
you critically evaluate everything and
there are let's be real some stories in
all religious texts that do sound
bonkers yeah and it's going to be
difficult for you to sit by and go
yeah but that's
that's right or that's wrong yeah yeah
because what if he turns to you and goes
daddy daddy is that true
i get that but then why would you deal
with that though because that's a good
question you kind of have to
have something prepared i guess it's
like when a kid a kid asks you how
babies
you kind of have to have something in
the back of your head where you're like
uh but it's actually very similar to
explaining um
like the facts of life and sex is a fact
of life right of to a child talk to your
uncle yeah and now that would be one of
my last classes
you know when when i was younger like my
mum was a sexual health worker and like
she was very open with me from being
quite young about like what the fact of
life is about sex and like you know we
talked about gay people and lesbians and
like what those people do and like all
these kind of things it's not really
from quite a young age
from like four or five but if that so so
i knew about the facts of sex but
obviously i didn't know about the
practicality of sex and i didn't know
why like in a four or five-year-old you
don't go oh you're doing it for pleasure
and then as you get older you realize
like obviously sex is also about
pleasure this is quite fascinating to me
because
you obviously come to things from a very
from the day i met you you've never been
a religious person yeah you've always
come at things from a very logical and
factual scientific approach
and then obviously let's say
you have a
naturally your kid is going to have a
questioning personality like he's going
to want to know everything yeah i can
already say that in him you know i mean
i can already see that yeah so he's
going to be asking certain questions now
there's going to be
the answer that comes from a muslim
family yeah and then there's going to be
what is dad things yeah naturally
they're not going to align all the time
right that's going to be an in because
it's tricky that it's a tricky one to um
you know if he says like is it wrong to
be
gay right that's a tricky answer and a
lot of can and a lot of what i would
term conservative muslims would say yeah
it's wrong it's it's not wrong but it is
wrong but and a few people are
hurting it yeah but i get what you mean
like there are a few things in there
which made me uncomfortable
uh for instance like how some homosexual
people are treated but very often and
the more i read into it the more i
realized um
how my approach
whilst it felt logical
was to some extent close-minded to what
um other people believe the way that
other people think and feel and what
they believe and the fact that i hadn't
lived in those places had probably
impacted what my
my approach was so for instance i come
from a christian society which is quite
different to what a muslim society would
raise me as right and so in looking into
it and obviously talking to flu at
length
our
rule from day one was it only matters
what mom and dad says and if mom and dad
say
um
this person here
you know
obviously people outside family will be
able to influence people but essentially
mom and dad are the people who get to
decide what is taught in the house sort
of thing do you know what i mean there
aren't grandparents that get to say well
you know maybe you try this or maybe you
try that and there aren't aunties or
uncles from either side you get to go
you know well actually it's this way
it's sort of like my dad get to decide
and i get that's not actually what
you're asking like you're saying at odds
is
atheism and religion right yeah and that
that's the the tricky thing is like
i guess
you guys are going to have to decide
prior to some of those questions maybe
oh no what 100 what yes what the sort of
stance is and that's kind of where i can
like
there are two things i can um compare it
to first of all sex and then politics so
you know when you're younger like
especially when i was younger i went to
a very liberal left university right and
i was all like yeah socialism like
socialism is the way like maybe even
communism is the way like i never said
that but there are a lot of people
around me you're like yeah i think
sharing things out in this very equal
way with the way but then as you get
older and you become more experienced
and
your mind changes from being like this
kind of extreme political mind which i
was definitely like atheist through and
through and instead of going down the
route of going so are my rules or your
rules right i kind of realized that was
a bit of a mugs game for me like i was i
was watching a lot of debates online and
i was trying to like work out what islam
meant to me because obviously my wife is
muslim and my son in in that way is
muslim as well and i was like i realized
the more i looked into i was like
all these people are talking about rules
and their interpretation of them i was
like
whatever i tell him it's going to be his
idea in the end of what he thinks of
these things i can have this idea of
what i want my son to be and i can have
this idea of he'll grow up to be a
footballer and he'll grow up or he'll
grow up to be a doctor but like
he's going to shape his own mind and
he'll take a lot from me but i'd hope
that the critical skills that i teach
him would allow him to go well i don't
agree with this that this says in this
religion like i
i believe what one's gonna love people
no matter what
without getting too personal because
obviously i don't wanna
uh you know i respect you guys and what
whatever you want to do is up to you but
it's it's it's more um interesting this
sort of thing because it's interesting i
imagine a lot of people have got this i
mean i'm sure a lot of people it could
be christianity like some people going
which i don't want to baptize my kid do
you know what i mean it's going to
become more and more
uh you know with the way london is for
example it's so multicultural it's gonna
be i'm sure a lot of people are having
this sort of
uh situation one of the nicest moments
and one thing that really took me over
the edge was
i'd never really spoken to my grandma
about religion
um for for a long time because when i
was a kid i was very staunchly like
atheist right and i was like oh god you
know god is so silly like that idea of
god is i never saw the the other
benefits of god if that makes sense so i
never thought
i'm not talking in a literal sense i'm
talking in the allegorical sense or like
the the sense of things not being
literal
and i was quite dismissive
and then my grandma was pretty much on a
deathbed for like three years you know
this i'd always go and see her like on
any weekend i could like snatch a day
here i just want to say what just to
paint this picture for people
lawrence is the greatest grandson of all
time right your dedication to her [__]
me it was unbelievable bro i'm actually
like
emotional yeah yeah i remember every
week after you because lauren's phoned
me when he found out and i remember
thinking
yeah i was crying on the phone
i'll never forget that i think i'll
actually never forget it and it was
actually like yeah like it was so
hard you know
and then
uh what do i say so
god bless her
nina
oh that was [__] brutal at me
honestly
she was sitting with flu and um
they went uh down that like religious
path and obviously my grandma was
christian
she was gonna die at some point
and she said like um
you're muslim right and flu is like yeah
do you think that's a problem and she
was like absolutely not like the
opposite of that like i think we're all
going to the same place anyway you and i
at least are going in a similar
direction and i was like that's a lovely
moment for them yeah right
and like i was sat there as the atheist
in the room being like
i'm the idiot here like i'm i'm the one
that's not seeing what's going on and
that was like an interesting point for
me because i started to go
okay your rules are getting in the way
of you making meaningful relationships
with other connections
and i knew at that point that i
something had to change in me and that's
something i had to reflect on my own
approach to other people yeah and
it was even like my own grandma i was
like i thought when she was dying i was
like oh i know everything about you and
like i know about your whole life like
but we went so far into our her life
story and how i felt about flu being
married all these things because she
wanted to cover everything before she
died yeah
and
sorry bro no
yeah like it's emotional but like it's a
good way
and
with that that taught me so many lessons
that i couldn't and
how arrogant i probably was
or not arrogant but like i just i didn't
have that other perspective to know i
learned so much from her in a very short
space time
that
it changed my it changed my life in that
sense and it changed how i then started
to treat my marriage my like approach to
flu and
her religion
and i'd been fasting before that and i'd
like tried to understand it but it
opened up this
whole new sense and i get like people
are oh i've had a revelation in my life
i'm not talking about that i'm just
talking about
it it was just an a different
perspective and it felt like a turning
point in that sense
it just made a big difference to me and
i stopped thinking of myself as like
you're the atheist she's the muslim you
two won't understand each other because
we also realize like that's not going to
make a healthy house for our own son do
you know what i mean like you're not
going to be in a good place yeah and
that that is now my approach and i'm
probably not at the end here oh no but
uh it it's made it way more interesting
and i've read so much interesting stuff
and
i'm probably you know it probably makes
me a more boring podcast because all my
answers now are more like yeah but i
don't really know
but actually a podcast you can't like
especially modern podcasts people take a
position and then go here's my staunch
position on x do you know what i mean
yeah and it makes me a boring pocket
that's why i love that russell brand
podcast because so many times you and i
were sat there just going
we have no idea how to follow up to this
do you know what i mean yeah it was more
questions than answers but i think then
that's when you know you're being more
truthful right i think people who do
speak in absolutes
you know unless it's about
you know we debate football and things
like that where you've got stats and all
of that and it's part of the show to
have a bit of fun with it and take a
position sometimes but but even then at
the end
essentially you're both sort of going
down that same well you're literally
trying to predict the future by coming
out with an absolute answer and that's
what's funny about it like you know in
football um there is that element of
well you've either got to be right or
wrong
at some point like you realize actually
the fun is in the conversation you're
having not in the answer that you get
like people watch the kickoff not
because they go i want you to defend
ronaldo staunchly but they like to watch
you debate ronaldo and they like the
circus
or messi or whoever i think some some do
i think some do literally believe in
in the absolutes of he's right he's
wrong he's great he's terrible yeah
because i've read the comments yeah the
ages are going about it and it was a bit
like that you know what i mean that's
why you know when i i had my whole
episode earlier in the year um or last
year
i was i had gone through all that
process of and uh i had so much
reflection on myself
i didn't want to argue with people about
me
i was just like yeah think what you want
sort of thing like i'm i know i don't
need to argue with you about life or
or who you are as intentionally right
you're gonna think about what you think
and you're going to believe that and no
matter how much i tell you my god is
real you're going to believe that your
god is real as well and at that point
their god was you're a terrible person
and you're awful and you deserve never
to be on the internet again we should
just well probably correct but you know
i'm glad we've grown up like
i'm glad we're growing guys yeah like
there's i i you know the podcast we we
did two years ago where we probably went
i'm glad we've grown up we probably look
back on that now and go i'm glad i've
grown up since then yeah but uh i mean
look
it never stops does it but what i mean
is is i think that that mentality of
um
cancellation and and just speaking in
absolutes and you know one person's good
one person's bad right and wrong or
like it's never the smart way to go
um you never like i think we've always
seen anything to be fair
i think we've always known that to a
degree it's just
in comedy which is what we often try and
do
saying something that's outrageous and
and like utter fact and also taking a
position is funny sometimes yeah but
like
like some of my favorite comedians
say that deliberately that they agree
with terrible things for comedic effect
and i think uh
unfortunately
you can so easily misrepresent that um
and that's what i think happens with
religion a lot like that's been my
experiences there's a lot of things i
think in a lot of these books which they
sort of went there's no way anyone's
going to believe that is literal but
they'll understand the meaning of the
story and then 2000 years later there's
people on speaker's corner going
absolutely this thing is the absolute
thing that i'm basing my whole life on
and you're like bro i've seen someone in
london doing that the other day and i
just felt like
what happened bro what happened to your
life to end up on a [__] corner
shouting out like a [__] lunatic
right like these guys were babies once
these guys were kids once as well like
they had so much hope and so much
happiness and now they're on a corner
going and you were burning hell and
you're like i don't think you're
changing anyone's mind
literally i think you're what they think
is they're doing their bit so they
definitely get into heaven i think
that's what they're thinking is like if
i do this
i know there's millions upon millions of
people who are in religions but what i
mean is the strength of religion is on
the down because absolutely the the
generation like people yes people are
getting baptized but practicing
christians is at an all-time low
you know and and that's because
um we're learning how much we don't know
about the world and as we do that i
think it opens people's minds to
well if if if this is what i thought
yesterday and this is what i've learned
now then how wrong is 2000 years ago
sure for example if it doesn't adapt and
change and have more of a
questioning attitude to itself
i do wonder how long how much longer in
society obviously it'll be here for
another hundred years or whatever but it
gradually it will just fade especially
in this form
is what i'd say yeah in in because
well to you it isn't literal but to many
people it is very much lit right or
elements of it aren't to me i imagine
there are other bits that are literal
like i believe there probably was a a
man called muhammad there was a man
called jesus you know these people
probably existed as
figures in history but you know to what
extent
to what extent is it by the way
important that these things literally
happened like
the story still has the same meaning
whether jesus literally fed the 5 000
people or didn't well
one of the people
to some people though it clearly does
matter doesn't it it it it the the idea
of the magic of it
it's the supernatural it's the he was
the son of god and he will rise again
one day sure and he will come back and
what what i
learned from the people i spoke to
who had those beliefs is
they'd often been through such terrible
trauma earlier in their life that they
needed to clutch onto the hope
that this
almost superhero was going to come back
and save the day sure and that when
armageddon comes
jesus will be floating in the sky and
all of the people who've died will then
be risen
and welcomed into the new heaven sort of
thing that was there can i see the guest
list because a little bit of me is a bit
like listen
this person thought they were good at
religion i just want to check were they
or they go in hell yeah because some of
these people who were you know priests
and stuff some of them were [__] to
me when i was a kid and i don't mean in
the sense of like this guy touch me or
whatever and though i know a couple of
those priests in that school definitely
did some shady [__] like really
almost certainly like those kids eyes
changed when they came out of those
rooms they should get worse than hell
right yeah but does that guy go in
heaven because he spread enough of the
word do you know and that's where i'm
sort of like you can't argue
everything's silly little rockers
are you at a point though now where
your belief of well being an atheist
yeah has changed or would you still
class yourself because you you're doing
an awful lot of mental exploring here
yeah no i i sold search and some would
call it
well finding myself and asia
uh yeah are you what are martin sydney
written anything no i do feel like
there's a shift though you know um
no if i'm honest from my heart i'm still
an atheist you still think that's it i
still think that's it but i don't but
what i do believe is there's more weight
and more importance in religion
than i gave it in the past and as
someone who was atheist and is atheist i
was more dismissive than i should have
been of
the key messages
and for me i think the key messages are
not is jesus real or not what it taught
me to do was to accept an idea in my
heart or in my mind and then i would
begin to work that idea through and i'd
see the benefits of keeping that idea at
the front of my head
even though the idea i understood was
not the
end goal
so the fasting for me is not the end
goal it's what the benefits of fasting
and i describe religion in my mind i'm
not saying everyone has to see it like
this in the same way
god is not the end goal jesus is not the
end goal muhammad as a prophet is not
the end goal it's what those it's what
believing in those people and what
believing in those ideas does to your
life that makes your life better so
debating whether those people are real
or not
is a bit of a force for you
is not the game i want to get into
anymore for you i get that and
but for other people the end goal the
empty lane endo is heaven yeah yeah
that's the goal but i still believe i
think a lot of people
rather than taking a deeper meaning out
of it which i think you actually i'm
trying i don't know if i've got this no
but to me
it's a little bit more on the gervase
line of just be nice to people because
the reward is being nice right and
that's very similar to what i just said
basically exactly but a lot of
arseholes
kind of
don't really want to be nice but they'll
try and be nice for the sake of i want
to get into heaven right and i get why
at some point 2 000 years ago
someone may
or may not have concocted a story where
they thought we need to give these
[__] a reason not to chop each
other's heads off yes we'll call it
heaven yeah and because not a lot of
morals going out there in the morality
short out here in what is essentially
the wild west of 2000 years ago we need
to teach them you know something and
maybe someone smart came up with that
i'm not suggesting that it's all down to
that but
the ten commandments for example
you know you don't need them these days
we've got the law do you remember
a bloody good
start point yeah it's not it's not bad
it's not bad it's not bad don't kill
your neighbors also don't look at their
bloody wives do you know what i mean
don't even look at them don't even look
at them should have said you can look in
brackets but don't touch yeah exactly
they wouldn't have put that on the stone
because he was in yeah there was
actually a second one but he dropped it
on the way and he was like what in
brackets yeah i've got another
muffler well brackets
i'll explain that next chapter obviously
we spoke about your grandmother earlier
and um
are you
so do you have a dream about her
yeah do you know who does and my dad
dreams of her a lot but i do as well
makes sense and my dad had my dad and i
really had similar dreams but we believe
that my so there was a dream where my
son was talking to her okay and that was
like
mind-blowing in my head you know what i
mean like but she felt so real do you
know what i mean in that dream you go
wow because i dream about my mother
right almost every day right a lot
and that's where my brain goes
you know you just wonder don't you you
wonder is that was that a dream why is
it why does happen so often and a lot of
people could rationalize and go she's at
the full front of your mind yeah yeah
but but
not not always some days i'll go up my
mind with a blank canvas you can go to
bed with a blank campus in my head and
it just happens you know what i mean and
it happens so often and it's so real and
um and it does make you wonder doesn't
it like
you know they talk about the dream world
and and i've heard people you know who i
respect talk about that of like you know
this dreams are complex and there's a
lot going on there
um and i just wondered if maybe
if you'd thought because of
her showing up in your dreams
maybe there's more it may be this does
that make you question that you know
when you see your mum and your dreams
that but
to be true and how much do you think it
is how much is it a comforting thought
and how much is it a reality
well i'm not going to
act like it wouldn't give me comfort if
someone turned around and went actually
no heaven is real
you're gonna
i don't need that to get through the
days i'm not a religious like i get why
some people i've met [__] need
religion you know when they go y'all
need jesus like some people do need
jesus just to get through there's some
people out there and i'm thinking of
like little old ladies who've lost their
husband who just need to hold on for
that idea i'm not that kind of person
um
obviously in a preferred scenario you
get to see all your loved ones one day i
get that but i don't need that to get
through the day
the love that i've shared with
my mother is enough for me to last me
the rest of my life and know that
whether or not i will or i warned that
special relationship
to me
is still there
whether she's here or not the love is
still there it's not gone anywhere
things haven't changed
she she may not be here to have a
conversation
but that doesn't change i don't i don't
not feel her love and not feel my love
because she isn't here exactly to me
it's still very much in the in the room
you know what i mean so it's it's
interesting to to to put it like that
and i just thought i wonder if he has
dreams as well because it's when you
have those dreams that my brain goes oh
it was interesting and you know
obviously i never come to any conclusion
because there's just no hard
physical evidence that is what what
humans rely on but also like you know i
can't say wi-fi right now it doesn't
mean the internet's not [__] getting
broadcasted in this room right now so i
that's where my brain goes to like an
open-minded place where i'm like hey you
know i'm i may we we may see our loved
ones again one day we may not
but i think
where you're at with religion and that
you know you can take elements of it to
enhance your life and to be a good
person and to be a bit more open-minded
not you know shoot people down
no
you know yeah there's no
you know shots fired in an open-minded
way um is a healthy thing
uh
to come to
to just help you get on with the days
but also to
help
like understand my own wife do you know
me and to understand
her family i'm people that's what i'm
that's what i'm suggesting yeah
what i mean is not in a selfish way i
get that i think some people sort of
need to hold on to certain beliefs just
for them throw on sanity sometimes it's
the same in all walks of life like it's
the same in podcasting the second that
someone does a podcast because they're
doing it for the brand deal
the whole soul drains out of it the
second that someone you can tell when
someone's making youtube people need to
groom themselves i get that yeah and and
that's a great side benefit um or they
need to access the internet in other
parts of the world who knows but
there is a big issue with
you can tell when someone's doing
something for the money or when they're
not doing it with thugs for covering us
to plug exactly it depends on which um
but then
there are people who are always going to
question that and i think you ultimately
like lose your audience you know you
lose your congregation essentially
there's all these different people who
come online on youtube to try and find
little answers every now and again and
go through their same questions there's
probably people who are 18 who are
watching this who are
reading some of the books to what i was
reading when i was 18 and thinking put
the book down german i think we'll suck
this off um sack this off yeah we'll cut
this can that can we can we can we cut
the bit of him crying like a little baby
and me crying we edit that out no if
anything that's that's what we put in
the thumbnail
yeah
this has been another episode of a
podcast we haven't yet given a real
title to
um but it's it's just us two hanging out
let's cover the news to cover like you
know
general stuff sometimes you just have a
catch up in it basically you guys love
it
when we sit down and talk so we wanted
to save the guests for the
podcast the podcast and this is more we
need a look we need a title for it yeah
crying is not
a new series
someone suggested deep dives i did like
that or uh there was another one within
their three title suggestions i think
deep dives was a good one yeah there was
another one maybe we'll go through the
titles together we'll be back soon don't
forget uh stay tuned for all of your
good
content on our twitch channel
youtube channel we're going to be
interviewing people if you've got any
guests that you'd like us to interview
let us [__] know i'd like to see the
people about the uh you know the old
worlds and stuff that you're talking
about on the podcast that would be cool
yeah that would be really cool okay
i'll go
but for now big enough to laws check out
his channels i'm gonna put them in the
description
two channels he's got now two yeah went
from one to two unbelievable and uh
don't forget to hit that like button
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you later